okay let's bring you more on our top
story the political crisis in Niger a
delegation from the West African
Regional block Echo was has arrived in
the capital of nyami comes a day after
Regional defense Chiefs announced that
they do have a plan for military
intervention to reinstate the ousted
president Mohammed bazoom is removed
from office last month we're going to
bring in Nicholas Hawkins joining us
live now from Dakar this isn't the first
time that there's been a representation
from ecowas going to nyami the last one
wasn't regarded as very successful what
do they hope to achieve this time
foreign
that's right Rob they didn't even manage
to leave the airport last time the
ecowas the West African body sent a
delegation to the capital of Niger
niamey but this time they're expected to
meet uh Gerald Gianni the military Junta
leader but also they hope to meet the
democratically elected president
ousted president Mohammed bazoom that's
top on their agenda and tried to find
out about his health uh his health
conditions and this condition of
detention have deteriorated and that's
at least according to the U.S state
Department who have actually been quite
active in the Diplomatic front to try to
find an end to this deadlock but this
delegation the fact that they're being
received uh by General Jenny well that's
a small victory for the West African
body ecowas and as you mentioned it
comes on the heels of the heads of the
armies of the region getting together
Gathering to try to drum the beat of War
but of course that is not necessarily
echoing throughout the region here in
Senegal for instance there's been quite
a muted reaction at the idea of sending
troops on the ground
um diplomatic efforts is still their
priority here I'm just reading on the
wires here that apparently the new U.S
ambassador to Niger Kathleen Fitzgibbons
she has arrived in the capital and Yami
but she's not going to formally present
her credentials because of quote the
current political crisis as you say the
U.S playing uh our role in there but
this is coming at a time as we've been
talking about about increasing tensions
with regard to the ecowas Troops but I
understand also that there are people in
Niger who are signing up to serve with
the Nigerian Army
that's right there's an effort of
mobilizing uh the the the population to
get them to sign up to the Troops in
effect it's a way to Garner support
around the military coup but of course
in the region there's a lot of
skepticism around what is happening in
Nigerian people are acutely watching
what's happening they're watching it at
least how uh the West African body
ecowas is going to react to this latest
coup there's been six in a number of
years here in West Africa and so
um there's really a sense here that
there needs to be a return to uh
constitutional order and that's a real
test for the legitimacy of the West
African body echoas that's perceived by
some as a club for aging presidents that
use that institution to cling on to
power and it's worth noting that in Mali
Burkina Faso and Niger the presidents
the democratically elected president
that were ousted were one that were
running on a second term now in Niger it
was Muhammad bazim was a close Ally to
the previous president what what that
signifies for some in the population
they see democracy as a continuation for
aging leaders to cling on to power and
that's why you've seen some support
towards these coups in the region it's a
really creel crisis over the Democratic
institutions and that's what's at play
right now and that's why it's so
critical for this delegation to try to
find an end to the deadlock because what
happens in Niger will affect the region
as a whole Rob that's necklace talking
to us from Dhaka and Nick thank you very
much indeed